c'est pendant la crise il s'en est déjà
pris aux personnalités qui remettait en
cause les décisions du gouvernement
comme jean marie bigard je comprends pas
comment on peut donner une heure
d'antenne en direct un homme petit total
hier il a récidivé dans l'émission en
aparté sur canal+ s'attendait évidemment
le françois cluzet emporté engagé qui ne
mâche pas ses mots françois plus en a
remis une couche en taclant violemment
fabrice luchini une nouvelle fois jean
marie bigard à ceux dont je rien d'autre
à dire son du v10 prend pour qui suit la
montée sur les sur ses grands chevaux
depuis le début je suis gentil avec lui
j'ai toujours été sincère avec lui et
mais qu'ils seront même pas en question
il cherche même pas à savoir pourquoi je
les fais ma grand-mère façon on a
toujours dit j'y fais du bien bertrand
quitte laurent kagan
parce que les artistes
on n'entend qu'un super héros colère
contre eux alors qu'avaient s'il quitte
avec une étoile jaune n'a
bien sûr
marita déconner pour le chien raconte
d'ailleurs il est très possible que je
sois ce qui n'exclut pas non plus que je
sois aussi très intelligent et très
gentil tu vois ça n'a rien à voir donc
un point ça veut dire quoi être un pont
et en plus je me retrouve dans le box
des accusés avec fabrice luchini alors
là c'est la médaille quoi pour moi c'est
c'est mon oscar à moi quoi
un chasseur de tornades a filmé hier ces
images tournées au texas là on aperçoit
un pick-up retournés par les vents
violents
après plusieurs secondes le véhicule
retombe sur ses roues
et le conducteur redémarre comme si de
rien n'était
[Applaudissements]
j'ai beaucoup de mal à fermer ma gueule
que je ressens une injustice et là
françois cluzet encore une fois que que
j'adore je t'adore montclus mon truc lui
il faut absolument qu'on aille boire une
camomille tous les deux
ça va nous détendre comme on dit
d'ailleurs
est ce que j'aimerais bien vous revoir
un jour ça se dit comment en amharique
bon alan canonial un bond à la nuque à
managua la broye la haine ne gagne
adlène gagnant n'est même
pas mal
nina
mais gai gai non mais
c'est pas tout moche le jour t de paille
est alors clairement que ça leur plaise
nord pour les paillettes je mens le
coquillage tulle m comment ta maman
beaucoup mais sur une échelle de 1 à 10
tulle m comment entre 1 et 10 9 à 9 ah
ya encore un peu de boulot florence il
faudrait quoi pour que tu l'aies m'a dit
ce qu'elle
voit là ah bah c'est toujours le
problème 1 florence